during World War two most women were
doing their duty on the home front by
working in factories and looking after
the future generations of their
respective nations but there was one 24
year old Ukrainian woman named Ludmilla
Pavlichenko and she wasn't about to let
Nazi Germany take over her beloved USSR
with 309 confirmed kills Ludmilla
Pavlichenko became the most successful
female sniper in all of history
[Applause]
Ludmila Bulova was born on July the 12th
1916 in bila tserkva in Ukraine this was
just a year before the Bolshevik
Revolution when the Russian Empire was
transformed into the USSR she was raised
in a world where people had a zealous
enthusiasm for communism and women they
were beginning to enjoy the benefits of
the feminist ideals that came along with
it
her mother was a schoolteacher and her
father was a factory worker in San
Petersburg during the Bolshevik
Revolution he also fought for the Red
Army during the Russian Civil War after
a few years father worked his way up to
an executive position that required the
family to move to a different town every
year this meant that every year she was
forced to start over in a new school as
a young girl Bulova was considered to be
a bit of a tomboy because she preferred
to play outside with the boys
essentially spends her whole life
playing sports outside she was very
athletic and could do anything that a
boy could do when she was 14 years old
her family moved to the city of Kiev and
she was trying to make new friends one
of the boys in town was constantly
bragging that he was a real sharpshooter
annointed his arrogance but over thought
to herself that she could shoot as well
as any boy cut so he signed up to be a
part of a local shooting club and here's
the thing she was absolutely right she
had the natural talent and determination
to prove that she could succeed this
male-dominated sport soon enough she
began to win medals at all sorts of
marksmanship competitions one day she
went to the carnival with her friends
there was a booth set up with 12
different targets if he had one target
with the gun you got a prize Ludemann up
paid for 15 bullets knocked down all of
the 12 targets she said the man who ran
the place turned pale with alarm and
astonishment as he unfastened one prize
after another and piled up beside me
after letting him hand me the twelfth I
felt sorry for him and gave him back all
the prizes as a teenager she began
working at the Kiev Arsenal Factory they
made weapons so she was very literally
learning the ins and outs of guns as
time went on she became an expert in
firearms and her skill set improved
exponentially eager to complete her
education Ludmilla finished school a
year and a half earlier than appears at
the time it wasn't uncommon for young
women to drop out of school at an early
age in favour of working but she was
determined to go to college already a
high school graduate she married a young
man named Alexey Pavlichenko at the age
of 16
they had a son
they're named rostislav young women in
Russia they were expected to get married
and start having children in an early
age so this wasn't strange or scandalous
in any way and
unlike in other parts of the world the
USSR had pride in their women working
full-time and also raising a family it
was rare for women to become a
stay-at-home mom who focused on her own
children and husbands needs the only way
they were able to accomplish this was to
have the mindset that it takes a village
to raise a child
everyone took turns looking after the
children of the community of course this
is all part of the larger communist
ideal that the country as a whole was
more important than your individual
family Ludmila Pavlichenko she wanted
more in her life than just raising her
son and working in the Arsenal Factory
she wanted an education and she wanted a
career this ultimately led her to
getting a divorce even though she and
Alexei were married for a short while
Ludmilla continued to use her new last
name Pavlichenko after getting her
divorce finalized she became a history
major at Kiev University and plans to
become a teacher before the war the
upper management in the Arsenal factory
recommended her for a position in the
military engineering school but she
declines because she wasn't interested
in warfare she was about to finish a
bachelor's degree and she planned to go
on to earn her master's but before she
could complete her education the nazis
bombed her school in the summer of 1941
the Nazis invaded the Soviet Union with
their plan called Operation Barbarossa
the Battle of Kiev it brought the war
very literally to Lib Miller's front
door
the Nazis attacked from both the North
and the South making this the largest
encirclement in all of history but
Miller later said of these Nazi attacks
you do not know what it is to have bombs
falling all around you you do not know
what it is to see babies murdered women
and girls ravished by Hitler eyed beasts
you do not know what it is to find the
charred bodies of your own comrades
burns and tortured beyond recognition to
see rows of brave fine people people you
knew hanging along the roadside after
witnessing all of the death and
destruction brought home by the Germans
she was ready and willing to set aside
her dreams of becoming a teacher in
order to kill some Nazis she was 24
years old when she enlisted
the Soviet army but at first she was
actually denied because she was a woman
in 1941 there was a push for women to
replace their husbands jobs in the
factories and help secure the homefront
while the men went off to war the USSR
would eventually begin recruiting women
on a more regular basis in 1942 but
Pavlichenko was one of the rare ladies
who took the initiative to show up
without being asked men were accepted
into the army straight away of course
but as a lady she needed to prove that
she was actually capable of fighting and
killing some Nazis she was prepared for
their doubt though because she brought
with her her marksmanship medals after
seeing her skill said they allowed her
to enlist but the trials in proving
herself they were far from over the
Russians sent her to study at a sniper
school that would eventually be an all
women's sniper school established in
1942 but Ludmilla Pavlichenko she
volunteered so early that she had to go
to one that was filled with men the
officers they began to bully her and
during her initiation she was told that
she had to kill two German soldiers who
were standing in an open field if she
failed she was no longer allowed to be a
sniper and should have to return home
asking someone to do this especially a
rookie was nearly an impossible feat
during World War two the average sniper
needed multiple bullets to kill someone
not only that but the moment one soldier
was shot and killed the second would
immediately know to take cover and drop
to the grounds or indeed shoot back this
was also the first time that Miller
Pavlichenko would have killed another
human being but she did not complain she
took a deep breath and calmly killed
both Nazis with two quick head shots her
aim it was perfect but her cover was
blown the enemy begins fire in her
direction she said I have to admit I was
scared in my first real baptism of fire
I was in range of hot German fire as I
called out to our machine gunners to
cover me with returned fire and save me
as terrifying as their day must have
been she officially passed the test she
became a sniper in the Red Army
[Music]
the siege of a desert lasted from the
8th of August to the 16th of October
1941 during those 2 months of fighting
the Nazis lamella Pavlichenko achieved a
hundred and eighty seven confirmed kills
now at the time all Soviet snipers used
a Mosin Nagant
M 91/30 and many of them kept track of
their confirmed kills by cutting a notch
into the butt of their gun with a knife
one of the many reasons why Pavlichenko
was so successful at being a sniper was
that she had a deep-seated hatred for
the Nazis and no longer saw them as
human beings
hatred did not come to us all at once we
are a peace-loving people and we had to
learn to hate but fierce hatred rose
within us after we saw with her own eyes
what the Hitler beasts could do now we
hate the enemy too much to fear him one
day Ludmilla Pavlichenko is hiding
inside of a tree covered with the leaves
an enemy soldier figured out where she
was and began to shoot the tree knowing
that her cover was blown she
purposefully fell even though she was
still alive once she hit the ground she
laid still and played dead the battle
continued to rage on around her and the
bodies of a comrades fell near feet away
from her she waited until nightfall to
finally stand up and sneak her way back
to camp her comrades looked at her like
they were seeing her ghost everyone at
this point began calling her lady death
this near-death experience only made her
more cautious and she thought harder
about every single strategy she invented
tactics to distract the Nazis some of
these tricks included the things like
brightly covered scarves on plants but
after she is one of these tricks a few
times she knew that it was time to try
something new next was the Battle of
Sevastopol where she killed an
additional 70 soldiers bringing a new
total kill count to 257 her superior
officers knew the Pavlichenko
was needed as a counter sniper which
means that she was assigned to take out
other snipers which was significantly
more difficult than bringing down
regular soldiers during this time being
a counter sniper she would have to stay
in our hiding spot without moving for as
long as it took to take down the other
snipers on average it would take her 15
to 20 hours to spot and kill the enemy
sniper
Pavlichenko said the one of the most
common tricks that the Germans tried to
use was to toss a tin can which
glistened in the Sun if she shot at the
can it would give her position away
another common tactic was to use a dummy
in a German uniform hidden in the bushes
another soldier even brought a pet cat
with him and threw it out into the open
as if to give her a false sense of
security
once they exhausted their long list of
parlor tricks the sniper thought the
coast was clear and he would stand up
and that's the moment when she would
shoot him but there was at least one
German sniper that took three days of
laying still in a hiding spot without
any food or water
she went head to head with enemy snipers
36 times and she always came out
victorious there was one particular
battle where all of the senior officers
had been killed with everyone being of
equal rank no one knew what to do there
was no one willing to step up and take
over but Pavlichenko she took the
initiative and started shouting a plan
and what to do next at first some of the
men hesitated to listen to her until one
of them yelled cowards look at this
woman Pavlichenko has the balls of a man
that comment was enough to snap them out
of their fear and the men agreed to go
with her because of her they all made it
out alive but of course the war wasn't
just filled with triumphant moments like
this she witnessed truly gruesome things
that would haunt her for the rest of her
life one such moment was when the Nazis
had occupied a town called softcore
silica just outside of Edessa the Red
Army managed to defend the city and the
soldiers began to check in on the
civilians and give medical attention to
those in need the Miller Pavlichenko was
one of the soldiers who rushed to the
local retirement home to make sure that
the elderly people were alright it was
early morning and the Sun was just
rising and we went in to set the people
there free but what we found were the
bodies of a hundred and eight people
shot and tortured sash to pieces 108
people all of them old and ill and so
depraved those HIPPA rights that the old
women had all been raped with every
passing moment Pavlichenko was finding
more and more motivation to keep on
killing Nazis eventually her kill
counter was raised to a total of three
hundred and nine not counting the first
two men that she'd killed more and more
people began to whisper stories about
Pavlichenko she began rising in the
ranks of the Red Army and became a left
tenant after a while that Miller had
leshenka had a reputation that preceded
her when the Germans knew that she was
across enemy lines they would shout that
she was going to be cut into 309 pieces
other times that Germans would offer to
give her chocolate if she came over to
their side but this didn't rattle her
nerves if anything it only a Mew staff
she knew that if they were calling her
by name as men's that they knew who she
was
they were truly terrified of her the
feeling I have after killing a Nazi is
the feeling of a hunter who has killed a
beast of prey
every time my bullet fells a Nazi I have
the feeling that I've saved lives now
they say that all is fair in love and
war but for Ludmilla Pavlichenko she got
a bit of both she fell in love with the
fellow sniper named sergeant major
Leonard tkachenko unfortunately we don't
know much about this man because there
are very few records that exist outside
of her very brief mention of him in her
speeches they were married during the
war but tragically tkachenko he was
killed in the line of duty Pavlichenko
herself was shot four times in the
course of the war shrapnel was also
scattered all over her body and yet she
continued to fight but there reached a
point when there was so much shrapnel in
her body that her health was on the
rapid declined and she had to be rushed
to the hospital she was honorably
discharged back to her home in the
Ukraine and became reunited with her son
however without a beloved katenka there
was a hole missing in her heart she
couldn't settle down and start her life
for her the war it wasn't over and her
opportunity to fight Nazis in another
way was just around the corner
[Music]
for years the United States it refrains
from getting involved in world war two
but in 1941 the Japanese attacked Pearl
Harbor the United States sent soldiers
to fight the Japanese but they didn't
send any of the men to Europe for a few
more years Joseph Stalin reached out to
Franklin Delano Roosevelt for help in
what they called the second front
however it was hard enough to convince
Americans to sacrifice their lives in
the first place and they desperately
needed public approval before Roosevelt
began to send troops to Europe one of
their strategies was to have Lyudmila
Pavlichenko go on an American tour to
speak to audiences about her story
Roosevelt believed that by seeing that
even women were fighting in Russia that
this would actually hurt the pride of
American men and make them feel more
inclined to go to war but Miller
Pavlichenko she traveled to the United
States in 1942 but instead of respecting
her amazing accomplishments American
reporters they were quite rude they
asked her why she did not wear makeup or
styler hair another asked how she felt
about the boxy military uniform that
made her look fat one writer for The
Washington Post Malvina Linz even wrote
the Pavlichenko should have worn makeup
on the battlefield in her article it
said isn't it a part of military
philosophy that an efficient warrior
takes pride in his appearance isn't Joan
of Arc always pictured in beautiful and
shining armor as ridiculous as it sounds
about Lerch Anka had to make a public
statement of the American media that
when you're getting shot at you don't
exactly have time to worry about
powdering your nose First Lady Eleanor
Roosevelt was on the tour as well and
she was quietly seething when she saw
what was going on with all of this
pressure being put on her shoulders
Ballard Schenker felt understandably
awkward during her speeches she could
not speak English so a Russian
translator was there to help her after
the first speech mrs. Roosevelt decided
to take Ludmilla Pavlichenko under her
wing she gave her advice on public
speaking as well as learning how to
ignore the reporters and their
outlandish questions during the talk
they traveled to a total of 43 different
states as time went on Pavlichenko got
more and more comfortable in front of
the crowd and she learned to smile and
stand with ease and confidences she told
her inspiring stories when reporters
asked her condescending questions she
was ready with witty answers why you'll
never necessarily expect these two
people to become close Eleanor Roosevelt
and develop have two Changkat they
became very good friends and they were
sad to say goodbye
[Music]
after her American tour Pavlichenko
returned home to the Ukraine photographs
and excerpts from her life story they
were printed in newspapers all over the
world and she became a national symbol
of women in the USSR in 1943 she was
honored by being featured on a Russian
postage stamp even though she is one of
the most celebrated female Gunners
Ludmila Pavlichenko was far from being
the only hero of the Red Army a woman
named Nina on a lever left a factory job
to handle a machine gun she became known
as anchor the machine gunner despite her
success she was killed early on in the
war and posthumously awarded a medal
naming her a Hero of the Soviet Union it
was also another accomplished female
sniper named rose of Shanina who was
nicknamed the unseen terror of Prussia
after World War II was over the Cold War
began
the Soviets they were no longer friends
of the Americans 15 years after meeting
her Eleanor Roosevelt could not help but
wonder what happened do admit I
Pavlichenko they had been dear friends
during the tour but she had no way of
contacting her from behind the Iron
Curtain mrs. Roosevelt traveled to the
Soviet Union but of course she got a lot
of pushback from the government it was
incredibly difficult to find out where
Pavlichenko actually lived when Ellen
Roosevelt eventually did find a
Pavlichenko had returned to her hometown
and finished her studies of the newly
rebuilt Kiev University she finished her
master's degree in history instead of
becoming a teacher she was given the
more prestigious job as a research
specialist for the Soviet Navy she had
gotten married again and was living a
happy and comfortable life Lyudmila
Pavlichenko passed away in 1974 when she
was 58 years old
but the story of her bravery has lived
on in 2015 a Russian movie called the
battle force of estoppel was made based
on her story even to this day no other
woman has been able to surpass her kill
account of 309 cementing her as the
greatest female sniper in history so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos just like
this several times a week so hit that
subscribe button then the notification
bell if you want to actually find out
when we put these videos out other
videos linked to on the screen now from
the archives and if you're looking for
even more from me check out my other
channel called today I found out you'll
find a link to that below and as always
thank you for what
[Music]